you know it's nice you that's the
reaction this man always gets genuine
enthusiasm not that crap I got up front
where they were a gunpoint told to be
happy for the old lady you you got you
got that people really are happy to see
you how much of that is because you're
from the Midwest you think and that
you're very in touch with being a
Midwestern guy ah there is something
about the Midwest there's something I
think that when you're from the flyover
States as they say yeah there's
something you just know you're not
living the place that it's cool to be
from right and so it it it's
character-building right house the way I
would as what I would tell myself yeah
but but there is something about I look
back at some of the you know my friends
I went to school with and nobody gets
too too big for their britches right
they probably don't let you may think
you know I don't think I don't think so
I don't think you're allowed to have
like a big you know it's like it's sort
of instilled in you there's good
Midwestern values I think that you have
I don't know but I do I do I do notice
when I go back there that everybody is
seems to be chilled out and happy like
if you go to the grocery store people
they're like hey uh ringing you up hey
have a great one thanks people talk to
each other they're nice it's kind of
weird
yeah but it's nice no I don't like that
I don't like that at all I'm immediately
suspicious of that when I'm in a store
and someone says hey how you doing pal
and like hey let's just get the
groceries and go are you god
and I lived in New York City for 25
years it's it's not you know it's kind
of the opposite yeah but I don't know I
feel when I go back to Kansas City and
you know my family's still there and ice
it's a night it's a nice town you know
you also you've been loyal to your
sports teams you know which is it's not
you're one of these phonies that went to
one of the coasts and then suddenly took
up their sports team right you grew up
being a cheap spin actually it wasn't
even until I kind of moved away from
Kansas City that I really started get I
was always a Royals fan and I like the
Chiefs okay but I really started rooting
for the Chiefs when I left I think for
that same reason I felt like nobody's a
Chiefs fan unless they're from Kansas
City right it just they were always kind
of overlooked when I was a kid you were
either Cowboys or Steelers there were
like two teams and I was Steelers all
but here were Steelers as a little kid
because I mean what years are we talking
about was like like the late 50s like
the they had no helmets then I remember
that yeah it was all those the leather
helmets I forgot yeah 88 years old I
forgot yeah and so it's fine that was
the way the game was in it was intended
to be played it was like during the year
like that those glory years the
Superbowl years and I was a little kid
my whole room was just a shrine to the
Steelers did you get to go to Steelers
games I did I got to go I actually I
went to Three Rivers Stadium one time
when I was a kid and I went with a guy
that worked with my dad who somehow knew
Bradshaw and was able to get me into the
locker room which was I mean I couldn't
even these are my heroes I could even
imagine seeing them in real life let
alone like going into the locker room
and it was the most incredible thing
because I walked in and there they were
just all naked everybody's naked yes
it's a locker room but they're all
completely naked nine years old
and just like Mean Joe green dick and
balls right past my face which is trauma
just traumatic was he walking by or was
he waving it in front of you I don't
know is it was a little bit like looking
at the Sun Bradshaw and Bradshaw was so
nice and he was having a conversation
with me and he was just in a jockstrap
and I didn't even know I don't even
think I knew what a jockstrap was and I
just thought he's wearing really weird
underwear yeah he's a Broadway dancer no
but there's no but is underwear yeah if
you don't know what a jockstrap is
seeing that for the first time would be
upsetting yeah yeah it's like a bra for
your balls it's weird because afterward
you know I'd watch the game and it's a
little bit like it's a little bit like
going to awake and you know you see a
dead body and you could never forget
that image whenever you think of the
person and it's like well now I just
think of Terry Bradshaw oh wait so when
you see him now and he's on television I
still remember it burned into my brain
you're like a child that needs to draw
it for the court you know tell us what
you saw draw it we have but now you know
obviously like a big die hard cheese
hand I've taken my son to the locker
room at Arrowhead we've and the same
thing happen to my son when he was about
eight or nine years old and it's I feel
like I can talk to him about it like
shared trauma ya know we can say I love
that you gave your son that same trauma
that's the best part you see that see
that being around morning wake up son
I've got something special planned
I'd like to introduce you to Don Atari
PO be great if you still introduced him
to a naked Terry Bradshaw today I've
never seen Terry Bradshaw since yeah
III would like to get past it just talk
about it all right
I can arrange that I can arrange that